last night lizzo made history
[Music]
[Applause]
we just made history tonight
[Applause]
history and making history freaking cool
history is freaking cool you guys
lizzo twerked and played James Madison's
Crystal Flute from the 1800s it was
historic
so was the Hindenburg so was the
conquest of Constantinople not all
historic events are good or praiseworthy
I actually kind of like lizzo I do I
know I know it's not popular on the
right I like lizzo I think her music is
somewhat catchy The Outfits uh not not
my thing but the music's somewhat catchy
and as far as modern musical artists go
I stand her okay she is a surprisingly
skilled flautist all of that is true
but lizzo should not have been given
special permission to play James
Madison's flute for two reasons
first one because lizzo is not dignified
she could be dignified if she wanted to
be but she is not and it is degrading to
our nation for a lady simultaneously to
twerk and jiggle and degrade herself and
to play an historical artifact that
belonged to the father of the
Constitution Second lizzo should not
have been given special permission to
play the flute
because the entire performance was
intended as an act of hostility toward
James Madison toward the founding
fathers and toward the historical
American Nation
I don't think lizzo intended it as a
hostile act but the libs generally did
the New York Times reported quote it was
a symbolic moment as lizzo a hugely
popular black singer rapper and
songwriter played a Priceless instrument
that once belonged to a Founder whose
Virginia Plantation was built by
enslaved black workers and the flute had
been lent to her by Carla D Hayden the
first African-American and woman to lead
the Library of Congress
in other words
the performance was not to be an honor
it was set up and seen as an act of
revenge against a no-good long dead
racist and the the nation that he
represents
it was set up and reported as an act of
Liberation by a self-described victim of
Oppression I don't know what uh music
video for good means but I do know what
your vote means and that's a lot
your vote means everything to me it
means everything to making a change in
this country
[Music]
so remember when you're voting for your
favorite artist vote to change some of
these laws that are oppressing us
now lizzo of course is not oppressed and
our founding fathers were not oppressors
the country they established is not evil
and both the men and the country deserve
better than to be mocked with a twerk
I'm Michael Knowles as the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Gerardo Leon
who says if you or a loved one received
the covid vaccine you may be entitled to
compensation I know this is going to be
the commercials in 10 years 20 years
it's going to be the mesothelioma
commercials of the 2040s
except that big Pharma was able to give
itself such incredible liability
protections while it was peddling those
the covid vaccines on us the totally
safe and totally effective vaccines they
got so many legal protections they
actually probably won't be held liable
but maybe that should have been the
first warning hey why is Big Pharma
getting all of these special protections
if people get injured by the vaccine
when they tell us it's totally safe and
effective I don't know you got to
protect yourself okay you got to protect
your family your home when you want to
protect your home you got to check out
ring right now head on over to ring.com
Knowles you know this is the busy season
I'm traveling constantly I just got back
from a trip but I can rest easy because
I can count on the protection of ring
alarm you might be saying ring I thought
that was the video doorbell company yes
it is they have a great video doorbell
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door no matter where you are in the
world well they've got ring alarm as
well it's the award-winning home
security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe best of all you can easily
install yourself even I can do it it's
Michael proof and ring didn't just stop
there they changed the home security
game and then they changed it again with
ring alarm Pro
so ring alarm Pro allows you to protect
not just your physical home but your
digital home as well think about how
much of your life you spend online well
ring alarm prep protects the doors and
the windows and the physical place but
also your data your internet your Wi-Fi
this season you've got to become a pro
GoPro just like me with ring alarm Pro
learn more at ring.com Knowles that's
ring.com Knowles
speaking of women with is in their names
how's that I think that might be my
greatest transition ever speaking of
women with is in their names the climate
change activist Izzy cook
has just accidentally on television
exemplified
the the hypocrisy at the heart not just
of the environmentalist movement on the
left but of the left broadly
so we would have to apply to have like
approved events to be able to fly for
well that's one thing that you could
look at doing
am I allowed to go to Fiji is that
necessary
in the current climate crisis I don't
think that that's necessary when was the
last time you were on a plane
um
I'm not sure maybe
a few months ago to be honest where'd
you go
Fiji
Izzy
is he
don't you care about the climate Izzy of
course I care about the climate not
enough you went
Izzy come on mice are you serious
are you serious is he
this is of course the way to respond to
all of the alarmism all of the hysterics
about how the world is going to end you
just sort of laugh at it because you can
say Obviously the libs don't believe
this if the libs believed that getting
on an airplane was going to destroy the
entire world then they wouldn't do it or
they're just Stone Cold Psychopaths but
they do it they do it all the time and
so we don't need to take it seriously
the whole Davos crew that tells us that
we need to go eat bugs and we have to
stop living and we have to live in tiny
little pods and we can't have meat and
we can't go work and we can't travel and
we can't drive a car and we can't do
anything anymore that same crew
they all fly private jets halfway across
the world to go on a fun ski vacation
with a bunch of other Elites around the
world okay and so we don't need to take
that seriously
as a as a matter of life or death for
the world we do have to take it
seriously as a political movement
but we need to start examining the real
motivations here why why is it that
these very wealthy powerful influential
people want to Peddle the climate change
stuff is it because they really believe
in it most of the time I don't think it
is
most of the time I think it's a power
play it gives them more power the
technocracy more power the international
institutions more power the handful of
corporations that are wielding a lot of
influence on those other institutions it
gives them a lot more power think about
it with covid why did the most powerful
interests in the country push to shut
down the country during covet is it
really because they thought that
everyone was going to die if we were
closer than six feet away from one
another and we took that little hanky
off our face no of course not because
all of those people regularly would take
the little hanky off and they would
violate all the rules and Gavin Newsom
would show up to the French Laundry and
these CEOs and the oligarchs and the
Masters of the Universe would routinely
regularly violate their own coveted
rules
when they thought that the cameras
weren't rolling
so what is it is it just is it just
hypocrisy or is it just a failure to
live up to their standards no I think
there's a little bit more than that
think about covid covid represented the
largest transfer of wealth from the
lower classes to the upper classes ever
in the entire history of the world very
often there are there are Financial
motivations and power politics
motivations I was just in the Bronx
yesterday I was in this old wonderful
neighborhood I've been going to and
since I was a very little kid we would
do our grocery shopping there and I
don't know maybe being around those
Italian Americans it gives you a little
bit more of an edge and you you know it
gives you a little bit of that sense of
hold on what's really at play here is
someone really trying to pull one over
on us and so I think you got to just
laugh at it okay you got to laugh at it
then you got to examine where the real
motivations are
and then you you've got to be much
better armed to to fight back against
them I mean especially with covid they
were pushing this thing so so
preposterously with such determination
Joe Biden now as Floridians were
preparing for the arrival of hurricane
Ian Joe Biden was saying the best way to
prepare for a hurricane is to go get
vaccinated
let me be clear if you're in a state
where A hurricane's often strike like
Florida or the Gulf Coast or into Texas
a vital part of preparing for hurricane
season is to get vaccinated now
everything is more complicated if you're
not vaccinated in a hurricane or natural
disaster hits it's much more complicated
you know when the when the Twister is
coming and it sucks you up and it throws
you into the sky and you're spinning
around with you cows and Automobiles you
got to make sure that you don't catch
covet now that that warning from Biden
was was not it's been going viral now
because of the the hurricane that's
Landing in Florida it was not
specifically for Hurricane Ian it was
for hurricanes broadly but it's the same
broad brush that you're seeing with the
whole climate change agenda oh yeah you
know the the world is going to end how's
the world going to end well it's going
to be really hot
or it's going to be really cold or it's
going to be really rainy or it's going
to be really drier it's going to be
really whatever do what we if you want
to stop climate change what do you got
to do well you've got to give up some of
your political rights if you want to
stop climate change what you got to do
you got to give up some of your National
sovereignty you got to stop climate
change what do you got to do you got to
give up your wealth you got to shut down
a bunch of small businesses you got to
give special nice handouts and
privileges to coincidentally all the
people in industries that happen to be
buddies with the political ruling class
I don't think so
I think that's the sort of thing that we
can just laugh at okay
it's the sort of grandiose pie in the
sky
fear-mongering and promises that we can
just sort of Mock and you're not just
seeing it from Joe Biden you're seeing
it even from these apparently ostensibly
more Lucid Democrats you're seeing it
from from one of the most normal
Democrats in the country Amy Klobuchar
senator Amy Claudia jar the the sometime
presidential candidate for the Democrats
didn't go very far she's probably going
to try to run again it probably won't go
any anywhere this time either Amy
Klobuchar who I I had some respect for
because I feel she's one of the more
reasonable of the Dems damning with
faint brace perhaps she just said
that if you're concerned about
hurricanes that is why
you've got to go out and vote for
Democrats we just did something about
climate change for the first time in
decades that's why we've got to win this
as that hurricane Bears down on Florida
we got a win in the midterms we
understand that
really distasteful stuff by the way
people's not only property but lives are
seriously in danger in Florida now
they're saying well if you want to avoid
hurricanes you've got to vote for
Democrats there is one man in the
history of the world who can command the
weather and the weather listens okay one
man and it ain't Joe Biden it's not even
Barack Obama even though Obama said that
when he was elected the Seas would stop
Rising the planet would heal but no it's
not Obama one guy
walked around the earth about 2 000
years ago the rest of them are just
pretending
but that's what they will say it is for
the ones who are sincere about it it
shows the level of hubris on the left
they they really do believe that they
they can control every single thing
under the sun and for those who are just
being cynical and opportunistic they're
making promises that they know they can
never keep they cannot control the
weather their predictions almost always
are wrong these are people who have
demonstrated extreme incompetence and
deceit
and it's it's in many ways the silver
lining of covid is covid was just this
very intense distillation of all the pie
in the sky utopian promises that we get
from the libs and it all turned out to
be wrong or a lie it was either
accidentally wrong or intentionally
wrong and it was a little bit of both
from the libs either way I think it woke
a whole lot of people up to say man
something is seriously seriously wrong
here speaking of a lack of control
Vice magazine just tried to air a really
sort of sympathetic puff piece about the
reintegration of sex offenders back into
society and the the way that this
documentary ended I think is tells you
the entire story
we all out here in this world
and we all got to make it happen and
ain't nothing stopping me so like I'm
very hopeful and confident
[Music]
after this interview a chief sent a
picture of his penis to our producer
[Laughter]
I love you've got the platitude I I bet
knowing Vice I bet they really did try
to to make a puff piece about these poor
put upon sex offenders you know these
guys Society failed them if only a
society if only this racist
bigoted oppressive country Society
hadn't failed them then they wouldn't be
rapists or whatever
and I I do think they probably sincerely
tried to make that documentary and then
they film it and it is broadly
sympathetic and then you just get that
punch line at the end moments after that
interview moments after he this man
recited those platitudes we're all here
man we've got to get together you know
and just keep on doing it man whatever
uh he sent a photo of his genitals to
our producer
which reminds us that we need Prudence
okay
Prudence is a virtue that I keep coming
back to again and again and again
because the left has absolutely no
respect for the virtue of prudence and
many people on the right do not either
sometimes especially when I'm when I'm
discussing a political issue with the
more ideological people on the right the
more dogmatic doctrinal five bullet
points on the back of a napkin Manifesto
type of people on the right they'll say
Michael you need I want to hear the
principled ideological argument for why
we should ban marijuana but not tobacco
let's I'm just using an example or I I
want to hear the ideological principled
rationalist argument for why we
shouldn't have gay marriage or Michael I
want to hear whatever and I I say you
know
I don't need to give you I I think I
could in many cases but I don't think
that I need to be able to give you this
perfect modern
rationalistic kind of argument for for
my entire political program in society
I think we could we can use some
Prudence I remember when I was a student
I got to meet Anton and Scalia someone
asked him about gun control because they
said you know Justice Scalia you you
support the Second Amendment but you
think there are some limits here and I'm
not sure that the limits totally jive
with the original understanding of the
second amendment in the Constitution and
I don't understand why some guns can be
banned and other guns are not banned and
how would you determine exactly where
that line is
on the the limits of the Second
Amendment and scalia's answer has stuck
with me and I apply it to so many other
issues he said
how would I determine where the line is
on the Second Amendment
very carefully
this this answer infuriated the
ideologues and um certainly on the left
but on the right as well
but that's obviously the right answer
how do we determine
these sorts of limits in society how do
we determine when to show Mercy to
prisoners and and when to insist upon a
little bit more Justice when to go
lighter and let them out of prison and
reintegrate them into society and say
forget the past and when to put some
guard rails around these people how do
you do that
very carefully
you do it how do we deter why can't
lizzo play the flute lizzo if you oppose
lizzo playing the
sexist how do you would
a some other concert flowers to play
that flute yes I probably would but you
won't allow lizzo correct I don't think
lizzo should play the flute well well
why because I look at lizzo and she's
wearing a weird little leotard thing and
she's jiggling around half naked and
she's she's just behaving in a way
that's not not dignified
it's actually obscene whereas the
concert flautist wearing the white tie
and Tails is behaving in a way that is
dignified and so if I'm talking about a
national artifact from the from the
father of the Constitution I don't want
that to be degraded by being played
while a woman Jiggles around on stage
well but how Define dignity Michael defy
an obscenity Michael no I don't have to
do that I don't have to do it because
Justice Potter Stewart actually was
correct when he said yes it is a little
tricky to to Define obscenity
but you know it when you see it
you do we can do that we have the right
to do that in this country okay whether
the libs want to admit it or not
we have the right to use our use our
Prudence use our wisdom of repugnance to
use a phrase from the bioethicist Leon
Cass and just say you know like I can't
totally there was there was an article
that came out last week it said
why are gay same-sex
well I I guess those are the same thing
why are same-sex incestuous
relationships wrong
there's no possibility of procreation
there
so that bioethical consideration is off
the table so why is it wrong
you know I could give you a a pithy
enough explanation
but before I before I even would be
tempted to do that
because it just is because it just is
because we all know
deep down in our stomachs that that is
repugnant we have a prejudice against
that and that prejudice is good
Prejudice is not always bad Prejudice is
how we all survive
you don't want to be mean or unjust or
unfair but you certainly
we we have to rely on prejudices and
Instinct and and received wisdom
or we we wouldn't be able to do a damn
thing in the world if we had to write a
fleshed out rationalist
post-enlightenment treat us for
everything that we do all day long we
would never be able to do anything at
all
how do we
why do we put a lot of safeguards around
sex sex offenders even after they leave
prison well because we know that there's
a there's a real risk that they will
re-offend speaking of crime and
punishment
you've you've heard about the extremist
pro-lifers the domestic terrorists the
threats to our country that the doj and
the FBI and the body Administration are
warning about here's a story you
probably haven't heard about there's a
man
a 74 year old man who shot an 84 year
old pro-life woman as she was canvassing
to end abortion the pro-life lady was
not violent she was not creating a
public disturbance she was just
sweet little old lady trying to convince
people not to kill their babies 74 year
old lunatic pro-abortion leftist shoots
the woman
not only is he not in prison right now
not only is he not facing One Would
Imagine a serious punishment life in
prison capital punishment even
he hasn't even been arrested
you remember Mark Houck
we've been talking about him on the show
recently he's the the pro-life guy who
who was peacefully protesting in front
of an abortion clinic and some lunatic
leftist comes up starts screaming his 12
year old son the worst thing Mark hack
did was I guess sort of push the guy
away from his 12 year old son
for that the FBI shows up with 25 30
agents rifles drawn pointed at Mark
pointed at Mark's wife busts in on the
home seven kids there absolutely
traumatized from this because of Joe
Biden's Jack booted gestapo thugs but a
74 year old pro-abortion guy shoots an
84 year old pro-life lady because she's
pro-life uh the FBI's got more important
things to do the FBI's got to go raid
the former president's house the FBI's
got to go Point guns around the homes of
seven poor little kids
they won't even take a look at that
story why because
there were two Justice systems and
meanwhile you have privileged famous
Rich Elite get away with whatever they
want Libs claiming to be oppressed in
this country
and then you've got pro-lifers and there
was an 18 year old conservative who was
just murdered was just run over with a
car by a 40-something-year-old insane
Democrat
and then what is the Democrat gets fifty
thousand dollars Bond he can then go
free
that's it that's the way that criminal
justice actually works in America
speaking of the FBI intimidating
pro-lifers there's another one you I
promise you most of you out there have
not heard about this story
the FBI is harassing another pro-life
group this from Mary Margaret olahan
reporting it in Daily signal
pro-life sidewalk group pro-life Action
Ministries
was just intimidated by more FBI thugs
two FBI agents showed up to question a
pro-life activist who is praying outside
of Planned Parenthood in Saint Paul
uh so the the FBI shows up and and
they're talking about that that guy Mark
Houck they're talking about they're
talking about the the way that
pro-lifers are being
targeted in this country and then the
FBI shows up there again
you've got genuine threats to the
country
BLM burning the country down for eight
months antifa showing up all the time
Democrats murdering 18 year old
Republicans for being Republican you've
got assassination attempts on
conservative justices on the Supreme
Court you've got Republicans being
harassed everywhere they go you've got
you've got this that and the other thing
the FBI is only focused on the
pro-lifers
harassing the pro-lifers which which
makes me blame the agents I say this
just like I said it yesterday yes
they're good people who work for the FBI
and they do good work certainly they did
in the past these days who knows what
the FBI is up to other than this kind of
targeting
at this point though I blame the agents
these two agents should not have gone
out there they should refuse these
orders
very often at schools people will come
up to me or any speeches I give people
come up and say it's the same question
every every speech for that fail
Michael
how do I know when to stand up for my
beliefs and how to just sort of go along
to get along
get another paycheck make it through
another day get my degree get my
promotion and then I can be conservative
and you go it goes back to that issue I
was talking about earlier it goes back
to prudence
it's not just that you know you show up
freshman year of high school and your
teacher is a little bit liberal and you
walk into class with a Maga hat on
blowing a trumpet and you say we will We
Will Destroy All of You Libs you know
like like Khrushchev banging your shoe
on the lectern at the U.N we will
destroy you we will bury you no you
don't need to do that you don't need to
be totally flamboyant with your views
all of the time but
you can't just roll over
you can't just give up because then
there won't if you just constantly cave
on your beliefs or refuse to stand up
for them
then okay you get through freshman year
but then you'll stand up for it when
you're an upperclassman except you got
to get into a good college okay well
you'll but you then when you're in
college you'll you'll stand up for your
beliefs oh except you got to get that
good job don't you okay so once you get
the job though then you'll say well I'll
accept you now you're a first year at
this job you should probably keep your
head down once you get that promotion
though that's okay until you're in
middle management wow but now you know
look you got a family to feed you
probably can't rock the boat too much
all right well once you're the CEO and
then well okay you became a CEO that's
great but you're responsible to your
shareholders or to your investors okay
and then eventually you die and you've
never done anything and you've never
stood up for any of your beliefs and
you've gone along to get along
Prudence is a good way to to measure
when things have gone too far
when the president
is using his political appointees to
send federal law enforcement out almost
exclusively to harass
good peaceful people doing good peaceful
things standing up
for the most vulnerable people in
society little tiny babies who are being
murdered on mass by the libs
with the encouragement the funding of
the Biden Administration when you when
you see something that is so clearly
good
versus evil
you've got to stand up
and you cannot say well
I was just following orders well I was
going to no this is it this is the time
this is the time FBI agents
for those FBI agents listening to this
show this is the time refuse the orders
have integrity
you might lose your pension I don't know
you might lose some money
but I promise you you're going to feel a
lot better than in 10 years 20 years hey
Daddy hey Grandpa
what a gosh golly what did you do in the
FBI oh I had guns at the children of
pro-life advocates
because my boss the president was just
maniacally focused on killing babies
so that's what I did Sonny I served my
country that's right I harassed little
grannies in the street and I ignored it
when the pro-life grannies got shot by
The Lunatic pro-abortion people I just I
just spent all my time defending the
right the right quote unquote of the
pro-abortion people to kill more babies
that's what I did aren't you proud of me
Sonny no no they won't be proud of you
they won't be proud of you at all
speaking of the Biden Administration and
death
Joe Biden just stepped in it again as he
often does
Joe Biden and by it I mean his mouth he
put his foot right in his mouth he was
at an event the White House conference
on Hunger nutrition and health and as he
was doing his Slappy on the back
sempering hey there buddy kind of
politician routine he asked where where
one number of congresses a woman named
Jackie and
uh bizarrely and unfortunately Jackie is
dead and so many of you know so much
about this as well and you're committed
and I want to thank all of you here for
including bipartisan elected officials
like representative Governor Senator
Braun Senator Booker representative
Jackie are you here where's Jackie I
don't think she she was going to be here
where's where's Jackie so if you look at
the people who were involved in this
issue the only person named Jackie would
be Jackie wolorski a republican member
of Congress from Indiana who died a
month ago in a car accident
if if Joe Biden were your grandpa
and or Joe Biden were some aged member
of your family and he said this sort of
thing you would not be surprised
you know sometimes people who are senile
and in Decline they forget these things
they forget they they forget who's died
and they don't keep up on the news
but Joe Biden is the president of the
United States
Joe Biden should be following the news
at least
Joe Biden should know when a member of
Congress dies these are the people that
he's got to work with
or fight against to get legislation
passed
this is not just oh well you know look
there's a lot of members of Congress
well the president's got a lot on his
plate yeah I
that was a pretty big news story when
she died
and members of Congress are pretty
important to the president in both
parties
he should he should know this and the
fact that he doesn't
again I think buttress is my thesis that
Joe Biden is not running the show
there's a big debate even on the right
is Joe Biden really in charge and not
people whose opinions I respect came
came out and they said no I think Joe
Biden is in charge you know the buck
stops with the president okay we can't
just blame it on some shadowy cabal I
think he really is giving the calls
no I think everything that we've seen
in the last year and a half
or more than a year and a half now shows
that Joe Biden is not really the one
making these calls actually the evidence
of this by the way is that when Joe
Biden makes a statement on policy
himself that contradicts what
the powers that be want then the White
House comes out and clarifies and
changes the the the policy you saw this
especially when Joe Biden said yeah
we're going to defend Taiwan we're going
to defend Taiwan and then the White
House came out and said no no we support
the one child policy one child policy
the one China policy not the one child
policy which you're not even trying to
support anymore
well what is the White House
you see this report the White House said
right it's using a a
literary tool to to say that referring
to this building as the power that that
is making these decisions but Joe Biden
is supposed to be the executive who
represents that power so how is Joe
Biden at odds ever with the White House
well they're right they're both they're
both metanims they're and they're
supposed to be the same editing but
they're not white because Joe Biden is
obviously not
calling the shots now the White House
had to come out and clarify and in this
case Kareem Jean-Pierre the president's
spokesman
once again gas let the press and the
American people and said oh I don't
think there's anything weird about the
president asking where the dead member
of Congress was at the event does the
president think that she's living and in
the roof I don't find that confusing I
mean I think many people can speak to
sometimes when you have someone top of
mind they are a top of Mind exactly that
and it is also if you put it into the
context it's not like it happened
without outside of context right it
happened at an event
where we were
um uh champ we were calling out the
Champions uh Congressional champions in
particular of this issue this important
issue when it comes to food insecurities
he was at an event you all saw you all
watched which is why you're asking the
question right where he was calling out
again uh Congressional leaders a
bipartisan uh leadership that we have
seen on this particular issue and uh
again he's going to see her family in
just two days and and she was on top of
mine I mean I don't that is I mean that
is uh that is not an unusual uh unusual
scenario there
It's Not Unusual when senile people
get confused and think that dead people
are still alive that is not unusual if
you've ever had a parent or a
grandparent who's fallen into senility
you will say Hey where's aunt and
Josephine he's like oh grandma Aunt
Josephine died 20 years ago that's not
unusual it's unusual when the president
of the United States does that it's
unusual we've got a completely senile
president and it's just this gaslighting
that drives me so crazy
it it's actually somewhat similar to
what we're seeing from the media with
the lizzo James Madison flute Saga where
lizzo is allowed to play this flute and
jiggles on stage in this sort of
pornographic costume this obscene
grotesque started performance
I'm playing James Madison's flute the
father of a concert look at my little
jiggling wiggle wiggle wiggle and then
and then you say oh that's not that
doesn't seem right and say why what's
wrong with that what's wrong why are you
so offended by that what
you're obviously trying to offend me the
whole performance is offensive and gross
and grotesque as a historical matter and
just as an aesthetic matter it's just
gross and and you're doing it
intentionally to get a rise out of me
and then when you do get a rise out of
me you Gaslight me so why why is that so
offensive what's what's so wrong it's
like they're just standing there like
hey hey not touching not touching
they're moving their hands right one
inch from your face not touching not
touching then you smack their hand away
they say why'd you hit me why come on
why are you so triggered no you're
obviously
trying to provoke me and get get a rise
out of me now you're you're gaslighting
me about it the whole time that's what I
find I find it even more offensive
than
than Joe Biden calling out a dead
Congress Congress lady's name yeah he's
senile okay I don't I it's it's weird
it's sad but I don't I find it much more
offensive when you Gaslight me about it
I find it much more offensive even than
when lizzo does this grotesque display
with James Madison's flute I find it
much more offensive when you then
Gaslight me say why oh what's so wrong
what's wrong with it are you just a big
racist sexist this is thatist
no not I'm not any of those things I'm
just a normal person do you like money
normal people like money
specifically do you like making
companies money
saving companies money making other
people save money who would otherwise
spend it well have we got a job for you
daily wire has a nashville-based opening
for a Chief Financial Officer the CFO
will oversee our accounting FPA and AD
sales teams eight to ten years of
experience in financial management is
ideal as is someone who is energized by
the daily wire Mission and ready to
operate at an intensely Fast Pace prior
relevant experience within an
established Media or subscription-based
organization is required agility as a
leader is key the company is in hyper
growth mode and we constantly break and
rebuild things to successfully scale at
the rate that we do if this sounds like
you head on over to dailywire.com
careers to apply
speaking of Democrats downplaying
unpleasant things
John fetterman who is in a neck and neck
race with Dr Oz
down over in Pennsylvania John fetterman
is a radical left Democrat he said
infamously that if he had a magic wand
he could change whatever he could wanted
to change about Society the thing that
he would do is he would let murderers
out of prison that's not out of context
that's I'm not speaking hyperbolically
that's actually what he said
John fetterman who never held a real job
in his whole life who presents himself
as a Working Class Hero in his hoodie
and he's a tough looking guy he was
actually just on his parents allowance
and when I say allowance I'm not talking
about the two dollars a week you got as
a kid I'm talking about 50 Grand plus
per year to support his sort of Vagabond
derelict lifestyle John fetterman
just removed a certain section of his
website
but because the internet is forever we
got to see it
John fetterman has just removed the
black lives matter section of the
website which is really really weird
does John Federman no longer believe
that black lives matter
is John Federman admitting the black
lives matter is a sort of distasteful
organization that's obviously just a
criminal Enterprise anyway
and and not one to to tout your
supportive when you're running for
Senate or and this is most important
does John fetterman still support the
BLM organization
but does John fetterman realize that BLM
is not a popular organization among
actual voters
because what we've been told by the
Press by the ruling class is BLM is
wonderful it's the voice of the people
oh we all the good people support BLM
I think I don't know I know a lot of
people I know a lot of people of all
Races all around the country both
political parties I know very few people
some but but few people who actively
support BLM because blm's a criminal
organization that burned the country
down and killed dozens of people and
embezzled tens of millions of dollars
and it's just a total Shakedown racket
that would make the five families in New
York blush okay during their Heyday the
the the mafia in New York was not as
Brazen as the BLM organization over the
past several years
and what the Democrats are admitting
they're implicitly admitting this they
don't want to actually say it out loud
in these words but what John fetterman
is admitting by taking that off his
website is yeah people don't really like
this
and it's it's just like the mob actually
which is you know when the enforcers
come to your door they say hey do you
have a problem with Don Luigi over there
he said no no I love Don Luigi oh he's
great he's oh you guys do wonderful work
please here have a little bit more money
please
it's just like when the TV Camera show
up you say hey knock knock you love BLM
right oh yeah I love BLM oplm is great I
it's my favorite organization I I
changed my social media picture to a
black Square please take more money here
you can have some more money
during during
the riots in La businesses were posting
signs in their door and they'd say we're
black people please pass over us agents
of death
go get Whitey you don't get we don't
want but you know what else they would
post
the receipts from their donations to BLM
just just like the mafia worse than the
mafia
and as in the case with that Mafia When
when you get people actually in a
private conversation you say you really
support BLM I say wow you know they have
killed people
yeah well they do say it does seem kind
of like a Shakedown well that lady who
founded it why does she have so many
multi-million dollar mansions and some
of the nicest property in America
now the Democrats know that that doesn't
play
in public
and so as they head into the midterms
makes me feel as though there is at
least some Integrity left to our
electoral system
the Democrats don't want to completely
alienate the voters
but they're trying to downplay all of
this do not be fooled do not be fooled
the fact that it took him this long to
take BLM off his campaign website
now we're what are we 40 days out
outside of the election
tells you everything that you need to
know speaking of the libs trying to
control the internet
YouTube
removed that Viral speech of Georgia
Maloney you know that great Georgia
Maloney clip where
she comes out we've played it on the
show a couple of days ago this is the
new prime minister of Italy and she says
why is it that you're not allowed to
have a family anymore why is the family
the enemy why is the nation the enemy
why do the Liberals want to take away
all of our identities as a woman as a
mother as a Christian as an Italian they
want to do it because they want us all
to be just kind of globalist consumers
parent number one parent number two they
they want us to be birthing person they
want us to flood our countries with
foreign Nationals with no limit
whatsoever get rid of all our Traditions
all of our culture
it was a beautiful beautiful speech
articulate serious addressing the real
problems of course YouTube took it down
why did they take it out when they said
it violated Community guidelines
lizzo
jiggling around more than half naked
that doesn't violate Community
guidelines BLM threatening people forget
BLM elected Democrats threatening
Republicans that doesn't violate
Community guidelines
doctors quacks encouraging little kids
to chop off their genitals that doesn't
violate Community guidelines but a
modest defense of the family in the
nation that does
now YouTube had to reverse course they
had to put it back up
this is censorship again not just of a
basic idea not just of total common
sense
but of an elected head of state this is
the second time we've seen this and I
haven't seen this part of it discussed
when YouTube and Google and Facebook and
Twitter kicked Donald Trump off the
internet that was a major political
attack that was a restructuring of our
political order because you had a
handful of oligarchs globalist oligarchs
saying hey we're going to determine
who gets to be in the Public Square
including
who whether or not the duly elected
sitting president of the United States
gets to be in the Public Square what
that means is screw your democracy oh
you think you have a democracy you think
you have a republic no because in a
republic the Public Square is how you
govern yourself you debate things you
deliberate you persuade your fellow
citizens not only are we not going to
let you regular private citizen into the
Public Square that guy that you elected
through your Democratic processes yet
he's not going to be allowed in either
because we rule you
it was a shocking power grab by the
globalist oligarchy against the American
people in our Republican form of
government and now they just did it
again with George and Maloney
right after she got elected
they reversed course for now the
blowback was too intense they are going
to keep
doing this this is how I know this woman
is great
it's how I know it's why I like this
woman
then I went on and I listened to what
she said and I look listen to the people
that she was quoting G.K Chesterton
Roger scrutin all of these wonderful and
I thought wow this is a serious woman
she really knows what she believes she's
really gotten things done
but forget all of that the fact that
that YouTube and the sort of globalist
oligarchs hate her
it takes me eighty percent of the way to
say I bet she's terrific
this is how I feel about Republican
politicians too
someone like Marjorie Taylor green for
example
she gets pilloried people call her all
sorts of names they attack her she's not
couth she's not this she didn't go to
some fancy schools she doesn't speak in
the most eloquent way a lot of the time
oh please even this is from the
conservatives forget about the liberals
who hate her guts but even the
conservatives oh we don't need to
associate with her I don't know she
wasn't precise in how she described okay
sure I I'll I'll take all of those
criticisms
I still like her why do I like her
because the libs
despise her
and they they seem to despise her for
all the right reasons
I can't it's very easy to say Marge
retailer green she's so awful she's so
terrible
it's very hard to point to the thing
that she did that's so singularly bad
what is it what is the thing that she
said or did that's so singularly awful
that conservatives should dump her
can you I don't know I can't I haven't
found it if you find it let me know I
I'm with Maloney oh no she's she's a
fascist
is she okay what did she say or do
that's so bad Oh Sheila you don't no you
don't look it's Italy you don't
understand no I said look I speak
Italian I'm Italian show me I'll I'll
translate for you show me the line that
she said that's so bad
well no it's and it's just all this
insinuation
and it's all this
implication but I don't I can't find
what it is as far as I'm concerned this
is my rule of thumb
if the libs
hate you and are out to get you and try
to silence you and do their best to kill
your career
I'm going to start at least from the
position of assuming you're a pretty
pretty great person
and before we go with Melania I've got
to get to one little clip I know we'll
run a little over but I don't care I'm
gonna get to One Clip with Maloney
Maloney comes out Emmanuel macron
attacked Maloney so the the head of
France attacks the new head of Italy and
says she's irresponsible and she's this
and she's that and instead of just
sitting back and taking it here's what
Maloney said
macro
Emmanuel macron described us as
cynics
irresponsible disgusting
and the Italian press did you hear what
macron said he said we're responsible
Emmanuel macron are those who bombed
Libya because they were concerned that
Italy would get good energy concessions
from Gaddafi
and left us with the chaos of illegal
immigration that we we are now
confronting
the cynics Emmanuel macron are the
French
who sent the uh gendarmory
to to return the immigrants back to
Italy when that when those same illegal
immigrants crossed from Italy into
France
and most of all
and because things have to be said right
and she goes on about the disgusting
okay
I love this this is this is like when
you when you go to prison and they say
on the first day of prison you gotta go
punch the biggest scariest looking guy
you can see there you got to go in sort
of guns blazing swinging you're ready to
go and establish your that's what she's
doing this woman was elected two or
three days ago and she goes in she says
I'm not going to take any of this crap
from anybody and she's setting the tone
and she's not backing down
and I say thank goodness thank goodness
in this moment where people are on the
fence and they're squishing and they say
oh I don't know is now the moment maybe
I'll just follow orders maybe I'll just
go get by no now is the time folks okay
now is the time the attacks on our
traditional way of life have become so
unbelievably intense so so many of us
never thought we'd get this far down the
slippery slope tranzing the kids
desecrating all of our revered National
figures
pornography everywhere radical
redefinitions of the most basic
institutions now it's now is the time
now is the time for the member block
okay the rest of the show is continuing
now we moved woke Wednesday to Thursday
because I was on the road so we've got a
video from The New York Times I have not
seen it yet I have been told this even
by New York Times standards is really
really horrific so I can't wait that'll
be great if you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member head on over click
the link in the description and join us
thank you
[Music]
[Music]